live I'm going to
do probably a quick morning session on
this hyperr
stuff and then uh we will see I think
there's going to be robotics to do
today what on Earth is this
I know this is yeah this will be quite
different
let's see um I think I
swept some additional hyper
parameters let me
see okay that's actually that's about on
par with
um with all of our previous stuff
we do get slightly
better coverage of the number of
environments it looks
like these are probably just
resamples yeah we get better coverage
here a little
Lambda these are definitely different
from before but they
are these are not anywhere near as
tightly
spread same with
learning
rate these are most likely
resamples time
steps ah and then this cost
here this is an issue because this is
not so there's still some work it looks
like to do here
cool we actually have good perf over
a a quite wide front of learning
rate so this is legitimate that that
it's uh it's sampling all of
these it looks like the resample is
buggy
here entropy is it's also stable
over a wide amount of entropy it looks
like
well
interesting these don't get
swept ah we actually do have
now good runs over the entire up to
Depot
front Okay so this is qualitatively very
different from
before possibly because some of these
are in the higher cost
regions but that's pretty cool that we
have this much more
stable
region now if we do cost less than 60
say
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this stupid
query
enter well this is [ __ ] that it's
not doing this
um
hello less than one
minute it just gave me greater than a
okay so now we
have we've got the main trunk of the
Paro front
here it still actually has much more
stable parameters that it's
found even update EPO at
good this is finding parameters that are
way more in line with what I would
E7 it looks like at 1 E7 we have a good
parameters
already oops
good now we get a bunch of other
preps got total time steps on
expected but it is a good
result 38 at 20 right
here oh I see what we need to do
do we have total time steps on here we
don't I missed a
as you can see here
right that a huge number of runs are
collapsed all the way back down to
here and that uh it looks like we've got
some of the highest perance here as well
benefit from going uh higher 20.2 two
well this point is
Paro there are a couple additional
parito points but not really not a
ton now the question here I think all of
these
runs and to be fair actually these
points some of these points are pretty
good
over here
unstable no it is stable it just didn't
learn
huh yeah there's nothing wrong with this
it's just learning
slow policy lost a little bit but not
really is this like some tiny learning
rate
I'm kind of surprised that this one is
bad oh these Max Brad norms and VF
things aren't great
these look like these would be pretty
good pramps they just learn too
slow interesting
enough okay I am curious to know if um
if one of the good sets of params
here
15 111
mil 35
seconds pretty low learning
size to high batch size but with one
Epoch so 16
updates it's not totally
crazy and then
96 97 okay I mean that's not too far out
of what is
reasonable it's fairly different from
what we got
before this didn't even go perfectly it
had a little dip
I think we just uh I think we just
rerun The
Sweep there were two changes one is the
total time steps
right e
oh yeah and then we wanted to
do the clean RL prams
and we'll see from
there no Cuda GPU is available
really
H that's weird
well I'm going to go rerun this sweep
and get a get breakfast just a short
little morning stream to check on
experiments um and then I will be back
in a